[Music]
and the clap is to bring this spirit out
to come and help us train so there's not
much point in clapping if there's no
house with no spirits in it
right so
okay um
i always um challenge my seniors as well
as i challenge the juniors you know
because this is what it's all about and
i tend to watch videos and think about
things so can you get a pen or
you might and can
so i was watching uh
i was watching a i felt a video of um
of nick doing tatty dory
and i said there's a small point wrong
i'll tell you when you come on the
seminar
so
when you've got a cake
and you're going to go and give somebody
a cake as a present
if you cut one slice out of it and you
took the cake and you said oh i made
this cake for you
anybody would think
why is there a bit missing
this is to me what takamusu aikido
and o senses aikido
it's that's why i decided to follow
you
because i see all these cakes
but i wasn't satisfied that they were
whole so that's what
now it's not very exciting i'm like you
know it's too it's more technical they
call it crab style well it's not very
nice is it but but it's because it's a
it's about detail
so if you like detail and you like
getting things
complete
now i don't know how true this is
because i've seen cytosensei do it the
same way as nick does it
but on a seminar he said
something up again
so the tattoo door is the one where you
so he comes in
he takes the can and he pushes my head
my and
ready
watch again
so here
he comes here
that's the that's what makes the
difference you see between
seeing aikido and knowing that it could
fail you see people do um
just do a show
i used to have a student do that i go
mike don't keep doing that i'm trying to
teach he goes will you find me scentsy
so i tried it again
the story says i can't help it
so his natural instincts kept doing that
so i learned it's better not to go here
so he pushes it away
but to go close to his key
that way i'm inside his arm length
right so
if you need to sit comfortably please do
so
so psychosensity said
when you come here
it might be attorney's head if you go
that way
but if you go
you lock his chin and his head we're not
going to do patchy dory i'm doing this
for nick
what i'm trying to say is
there's a small difference between
he can turn his head either way
and my hand will slip off
if i go
that way
that way so you add a bit of that
it goes in there
uh
everybody all you seniors all think
they're basic what's basic to you
kion but what is key on i mean these
people at the back there they want to
know what keon is
so we're going to work on keyhole
and look at um what makes the difference
so so that's all
change of they might turn their head
if you just push it away
or if you sort of try and do that
even if it looks like that as long as
you you're doing that
and i've since i tested since you do
this
then it locks them
what is
that's not basic
that's basic
so i'll tell you the answer if you
haven't seen already it's when
i have one hand
attached to my partner
because at any time my partner can take
his hand away
if i do so this isn't basic so a lot of
the the masters this chick stands and
that they'll go like this and i'm going
to face it
but you see the point is they had a bit
messing out the cake
yes it looks good doesn't it
so psycho sensei said i went to
i went to the hombu dojo and they were
teaching this
to their students is basic
but i like the technique so what i done
was
i went back to one and thought how can
we make it as close to basic as possible
and he said take it as quick
so he said make basic
even though it's not basic might face it
become
a smaller distance of time between
them escaping and you doing the
technique
so by doing taina hancock on basic
that means now
not
it's not me holding him one hand so when
we do techniques you should always be
attached that's basic
if you don't need to attach
that's basic
itself
so
you could say but he could let go at any
time
if i'm in front of him just half a foot
or quarter of a foot
i won't get him to come
round
so basically i was going to go deeper
and the depth of basic now is i'm going
to
i use the word the other day
there's osmosis and there's a moles
what was the word i use nigel
equilibrium
my foot is level with therefore
a wonderful wonderful master
tamura scentsy
he had this sort of like he could
actually
get inside the students
he can't pull back because my
equilibrium
is sort of gone into them
what's this what's this part
anymore he's no weight because i've
actually gone inside him so that's for
you seniors
i don't want you to all try and go at
100 miles an hour
some of us are older some of uh lots of
fit some of us have some problems you
should go a pace where you're going to
learn
and then you'll enjoy it you've got a
pace you think that you're 20 years
younger so you should do it fast you're
an idiot
there's a big difference between the two
so taina hank would start always down
the tongue thinker
they hold 100
don't show your fingers
they might grab hold of them
then you'll do four of
those when you've done four of those
you'll begin the diary and
do this
that's the most difficult one
okay